it's very easy to build a brand that's
relevant for two or three years but to
really build a brand that lasts
it really starts and ends with listening
to your community and building something
that they love name is kami telus and
i'm the ceo and founder of parade
i grew up going to the mall and seeing
and you know add two cups bra and you
know
these massive supermodels blown up on
the side of the building
they were over sexualizing women and i
knew that that
narrative had come to an end there was
time for a new brand to come along and
rewrite the american underwear story
the past two years starting parade we've
grown and we're now one of the fastest
growing ddc businesses
in the world i think to me the american
dream
is about imagination and the possibility
of
recasting yourself and you know the
world around you
the world is at a critical place where
the need for
young imaginative leaders is so much
greater
and i think that with that comes the
expectation and the need for vision
very few startups succeed most of them
fail and in that you know
we have a responsibility to swing for
the fences and think beyond just you
know one market
one customer think about how we can
really
re-write and redefine our entire
industries
you